well gentlemen welcome to the forge and
fire gambling
house now here's how it's going to work
we're going to spin the wheel of forging
which is going to give you a technique
you need to use for round one now
there's some that are pretty easy like
choose your own technique now we've got
things as hard as jelly roll
Damascus Chris you're up next come on up
let's see what you get in round one 200
layer Damascus are you happy with that
choice I'm very happy
right Damon test your luck in round one
e extremely close to Jelly Roll But you
land on 100 layer Damascus I'll take it
you happy with it yes sir all right Budd
100 layer Damascus his Cakewalk Johnny
you are up and think about taking what
were the first challenges that I know
how to
do in round one we are on raindrop the
Mascus you feel un comfortable with that
you bet good luck your time starts now I
stack all 24 pieces together to start
with with 24 layers my Billet is got to
be cut into five pieces to make a
120 layer then I'm going to have to cut
that in half and reweld that that will
give me a 240 layer
Billet I have to make rain drop Damascus
a full tank Chopper is what I have in
mind I only chose 10 pieces of Steel to
begin with because if part of this
villet would screw up then I would have
extra to fall back on starting out with
24 layers and I need to get to over 100
so I'm going to draw out the 24 layers
stack it in three which will give me 72
layers and then stack it again in two
and I get
144 I've made 100 layer Damascus a lot
but it can be a little bit tricky I need
to make sure that it's welded up real
well my Steel's moving pretty well draw
it out to at least 12 14 in so I can uh
cut it into
thirds I have 3 24 layer pieces I need
to get them cleaned up so I can restock
them and then stick them back in the
Forge and Forge W them again D seems to
be the only one that before he restacks
take the time to really clean out his
metal each and every time same is
working
smart setting that first weld is
critical and I have to do that several
times look at Chris's Billet
like the bottom third of the stack is is
a different color than the rest of the
stack still cold in the
center if these welds don't set I am
done oh look at that oh boy hurt I'm
freaking out right now but I realize 2/3
of it are a nice solid
Billet I'm just going to get rid of the
top piece and keep moving there you go
good take it get it out of of there it's
going to require more cuts and more
Forge welds to make 200 layers but it's
easier than starting from scratch so
Chris took his stack of 17 cut it into
seven pieces welding it together and
then he's going to end up with 119
layers good and he'll just need one more
cut and
stack now that the the bullet's all put
together I have to get to the drill
press and do the raindrops what makes a
raindrop pattern is to have multiple
layers
once you force that down into a b you
drill through that steel and then Forge
that all down so all the layers in that
hole that you've made now come to the
surface it's not easy putting the
raindrops into the dast steel because of
the the hardness of the steel so I make
the decision just to put a couple in on
both sides to try to get a staggered
formation so I can move on to the next
step in the process time to start
thinking about the quench if I get a
warp blade it's so thick it's going to
be hard to get it
out all right Damon's in the quench had
just a slight little war to it so I put
some weight on top of it and luck have
it it ended up
straight all right Chris is quenched as
well I pull it out and it's pretty darn
straight I am very
relieved I don't have time to
thermocycle the
blade Johnny it quenched his blade
hopefully nothing opened up or popped
loose I got a slight Warp
you have a short window of opportunity
after a quench to straight it out so now
I have to refine the profile of the
blade 5 4 3 2 one BL it turn off your
machines put down your tools round one
is
over all right gentlemen you know what
time it is it's time for the strength
test the rud let wheel
chop I'm going to be taking your blades
all of them have a Damascus construction
and mash them them into this roulette
wheel now remember this test is not
about what your blades do to the
roulette wheel it's what that roulette
wheel does to your blades P your up
first you ready yes sir
okay all right Chris right off your
blade held up perfectly there's
absolutely nothing wrong with your
handle construction but it would have
been nice if it was scaled up just a
little bit because there's not a lot of
meat there good job thank you very much
Damon you ready yes sir give it
[Music]
hell all right so damn it this blade is
easy to hold on to the flare that that
antler gives makes perfect retention you
got a really nice grind on on this it's
still sharp you took one little ding
right there other than that there's no
damage to the blade at all nicely done
thank you Johnny your turn you ready be
lying if I said
yes all right Johnny going to start with
the blade it is sharp it didn't take any
damage your handle this curve at the
back on a blade this heavy my hand tends
to want to slide down on that you did
pick up a little piece of wood right
there in that delamination but nothing
came apart H upgrading the strength test
good
job all right blad spits we know your
blades are strong but are they
sharp this is the playing card slice the
sharpness
test for this particular test it's all
about your Edge Ed are we all in yes sir
all right Chris you're up first you
ready for this I'm ready all right let's
do
this all right Chris let's talk about
your weapon here first up your edge here
cut all the cards through nothing was
crushed overall sir your weapon you a
cut thank you here all right Damon are
you ready to play cards with the Beast
yes sir all right let's do
it nice
yeah all right Damon let's talk about
your weapon here first up I like the
look of your blade it's very
intimidating I also like that you can
see all the these layers of Damascus
overall sir your weapon you will cut
thank you all right Johnny your turn sir
you ready Dave said it was sharp prove
him wrong all right let's see I took a
gamble on my edge geometry if you don't
have the right angle on your Edge that
cards are going to tear and rip if my
blade doesn't cut through the cards I
will be going
home
all right Johnny you talk up about your
blade here your Edge you really took a
gamble on the kind of grind that you
chose for this it was great for the
strength test but when you're cutting
through cards like this you need a finer
Edge so that kind of cut basically push
some cards aside and some of the cards
that did cut it's more of a shred rather
than a clean cut so overall sir your
weapon you will kind of cut thank you
you well gentlemen this is a high stakes
competition and you all turn in blades
that tested well in their own way but as
you know only two of you can move
forward in this competition which means
one of you is going home judges have
made the decision and the blades Smith
leaving the forge
is Johnny unfortunately your blade just
didn't make the cut and Jay's going to
tell you why Johnny you worked really
hard and we appreciate that there's some
issues with your handle and that skinny
Bushcraft grind on the Chopper really
didn't help you on the sharpness test
that's why we're letting you go I
understand well John you made a blade
that smashed through the strength test
but the cards don't lie unfortunately
you're not going to be moving forward in
this competition I'm going to have to
ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you very much for thank you
John thank you John good Johnny thanks
bud this was a tough competition it's
not as easy as it looks I'm not making
no excuses there are none it's just uh
luck of the
draw